queen again
one time wasn't enough
crazy
what am i doing i can't play this
this is stupid
we're a thousand rated this is
embarrassing to watch for everyone why
do this suggest what am i doing i can't
like two nights hanging completely
lost positions massive massive
what i'm doing
oh my god i feel bad watching this this
is like a mirror of me when i play
bullets sometimes
yeah
watching the pill that's so relatable
oh my god i can't i can't handle this
i have
and you remember at the beginning i was
saying like
the players are probably gonna say oh my
god i hate bullet what is this looks
stupid and then when they win they're
like i love bullets this is
amazing feels like that's what's
happening